we have a number of seats over on over
on this side over here there's a row of
about five or six seats on this this end
there's some seats down here in the
front and I see some seats scattered
through here as well right seat right
here I'll give you a bit of an
introduction
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen my
name is Jeff frenzel I'm the Dean of
undergraduate admissions here at Yale
and also the master of Timothy Dwight
college and a lecturer in the philosophy
department and I'm the steward of the
chubb fellowship at yale and i want to
tell you just a brief word about the
fellowship in 1949 a gift from yale
alumnus hendon Chubb launched a speaking
fellowship at yale to promote the notion
that service to the public good is the
highest calling to which any citizen can
aspire to be named the chub fellow is
Yale's most notable honor accorded to a
visiting speaker chub fellows have
included many heads of state and
national leaders Nobel and Pulitzer
Prize winners and a wide range of other
highly accomplished individuals in
political affairs nonprofit and
for-profit governance the literary and
fine arts whose experiences and
leadership have helped define the
challenges of our times and the ways
that we should seek to address them
before I introduce this spring's chub
fellowship recipient president leonel
fernandez i want to take a moment to
recognize another prominent citizen of
the Dominican Republic who has travelled
from Washington to be with us our
special guest the current ambassador of
the Dominican Republic to the United
States on a ball to crystal the castro
on ibadat castro
before his government service ambassador
to castro was a noted Dominican
journalist ultimately serving as
editor-in-chief of ultima hora then his
director of the newspaper he also
co-founded editorial a a publisher of
the groundbreaking socio-political
magazine rumble from 2000 until his
appointment in 2004 as ambassador of the
Dominican Republic to the United Kingdom
he directed the newspaper diario libre
after serving for six years as
ambassador from the Dominican Republic
to the United Kingdom he presented his
credentials to president barack obama as
the current Dominican ambassador to the
United States in July of 2011 welcome to
Yale mr. ambassador I also wanted to
welcome the several members of the
president's staff who are here with us
for his chubb fellowship visit including
especially yamila yamil a eusebio
director of the president global
foundation for democracy and development
in New York and his yummy lay here
everywhere finally I want to express the
special thanks of both Yale and the
chubb fellowship committee to the
Dominican students association of Yale
and in particular patricio Brito who has
worked for over two years to find a way
to bring president Fernandez to our
campus I might say that not only did
Patricios work result in a chub
fellowship recipient who is bringing us
a remarkable experience in public life
and an important message for our time
regarding Latin America but this
afternoon in a meeting with the
Dominican Students Association and also
the Latino student organization espanola
president Fernandez and officers and
alumni of the Association committed to
an important series of joint exchanges
among undergraduate and graduate
students of Dominican heritage in the
United States and the work especially in
education to which the president's
foundation is now committed so now let
me introduce briefly our distinguished
chubb fellowship visiting speed
president Lana Fernandez who this past
summer stepped down from his third term
of office as the elected president of
the Dominican Republic he was born there
1953 and came to New York City at the
age of eight attending school in this
country from 1962 until his return to
the Dominican Republic in 1971 in 1978
he graduated from the Autonomous
University of Santo Domingo with honors
in law he worked as a teacher and a
journalist and also practiced law before
entering politics as a follower and
protege of the noted Dominican thinker
writer and political leader Juan Bosch
founder of the Dominican liberation
party in 1996 as the presidential
candidate for the party mr. Fernandez
survived the first round of a heavily
contested election and won the second
round by a narrow margin elected at age
42 he is the youngest person ever to
have served in the office mr. Fernandez
vowed to end political corruption
implemented closer oversight of the
judiciary police and military and
promised greater scrutiny of state-owned
firms and reforms to strengthen
manufacturing and agriculture in 1999 he
announced an initiative to broaden the
country's economic base by attracting
high technology firms to the Dominican
Republic in 1998 he restored diplomatic
relations with Cuba constitutionally
barred from running for re-election mr.
Fernandez left office in two thousand in
2004 however he was returned to office
by a wide margin and he was reelected to
a third term in 2008 in 2011 mr.
Fernandez was pressured by some of his
partisans to pursue the further
amendment of the country's constitution
to allow him to serve yet another
consecutive term he opposed the change
to the Constitution and stepped down
from office this past summer both in
office and out president Fernandez has
sustained a focus on economic growth
and financial stability as the keys to
both political success and success of
the nation it is a fact that growth
rates in the Dominican Republic during
his terms of office have been among the
very highest in Latin America he has an
addition paid sustained attention to
education to food security to
agricultural development and to regional
cooperation as I have spent time with
him over the last two days I have
noticed something in particular and in
particular in his speaking to students
both last night at the chubb fellowship
dinner and Timothy Dwight college and
the students this afternoon from the
Latino organizations at Yale one thing
I've noted is he's extraordinarily
generous with his time and and and
access to his person I don't know how
many students he greeted last night but
it felt like it was virtually all of
them beyond that he is what I speaking
as a philosopher would call a pragmatist
philosopher and we think of pragmatism
generally speaking in a kind of common
everyday sense as getting things done
how do you get things done you're a
pragmatist you're not an idiot log you
you you work two to make the trains run
you you get things done however that's
not what pragmatism is as as a
philosophical movement philosophically
speaking pragmatism means that the that
the doing is the learning and I have
heard him say this several times over
the past two days to students that you
must get beyond your classrooms and you
must actually be in contact with the
work that you hope to engage in order to
learn what it is that you are going to
be doing a deeply pragmatic perspective
on education however I will say that at
the very same time he has shown an
extraordinary intellectual curiosity
both in his description of how he got
interested in politics and growing up
the self-taught
intellectual culture that he inhabited
both in in New York and in the Dominican
Republic and evidenced in even such
things as when he arrived in town
yesterday and I thought we'd all go out
to lunch he said no I'd actually like to
go to the bookstore and all of his staff
I know this we talked about it with the
students last night we spent the next
hour and a half his first hour and a
half in new haven in the Yale bookstore
and i think that the take at the end was
about 60 to 80 books that he was taking
back back home to add to the four
hundred thousand books that he has
collected for his foundation institute
and to and to accompany this afternoon's
conversations with the students about
intellectual exchanges where he shows
the other side of pragmatist philosophy
which is that the that the exchange the
very exchange of ideas brings people
together gives them a common experience
and a common vocabulary and allows them
to transmit practices and ideas and
relationships from one context to the
other and it was in that that modality
that he was hoping that this visit to
Yale would initiate exchanges between
the Dominican and other Latino students
here and what's happening in the
Dominican Republic so I would like you
to welcome this deeply and
philosophically pragmatic man president
leonel fernandez
thank you master pencil for your very
kind and warm introduction and thank you
for all the generosity that you've shown
in the last two days he even took me to
a Cuban restaurant the first day I was
here thank you Elijah it was very good
thank you also for your presence
ambassador and even the castro and to
all of you for being here today over 50
years ago in his commencement speech
year at Yale president john f kennedy
began by stating that he had the best of
two worlds a Harvard education and a
Yale degree well right from the
beginning I have to admit openly and
honestly that I have not been so
fortunate in experiencing the wonders of
neither of those two academic worlds
nonetheless it is an honor and a
privilege to be here today at this
prestigious institution of higher
learning from where two prominent
Latinos were educated becoming for many
a source of inspiration Supreme Court
Justice Sonia Sotomayor and former
mexican president ernesto city you I am
also very pleased to know there is a
group of young and talented Dominican
students here at Yale who have organized
themselves since 2005 in a very creative
manner within the Dominican Student
Association called kis ka Lee's we have
kiss kiya it is the original name of our
country so they have Mexica Scalia with
the Yale calling themselves kiss ka
lease and personally I not only
delighted to find a Dominican and Latino
presence in this very bribe and
intellectual environment but also
thrilled to share with you the news that
even though a small nation the Dominican
Republic my country very recently gained
a respected status as a world power in a
particular field of interest and great
following here in the US can you get
what baseball
just a couple of weeks ago the Dominican
Republic thank you all right just a
couple of weeks ago the Dominican
Republic which can also be called
baseball and became the undefeated
champion of the world baseball classic
in that and it is with that distinction
and sense of national pride that I
express my gratitude to yells
authorities faculty members and students
for inviting me to address you on the
relevance of Latin America and the
Caribbean in the 21st century as you all
know Latin America and the Caribbean
represent a region of 33 independent and
sovereign states extending from the Rio
Grande this is Texas and New Mexico to
the southern tip of South America
covering an area two and a half times
the size of the u.s. it accounts for
nearly four percent of the Earth's
surface and can be divided into several
sub regions such as Mesoamerica which
includes Mexico and Central America the
Indians and southern cone countries in
South America and the Caribbean islands
at this moment nearly 600 million people
live in the area in 1900 the population
was made up of 60 million people 50
years later in nineteen fifty it came up
to 150 million people which at that time
equals the population of the united
states since then up till now sixty
years later it has quadrupled and is
almost a doubles of current US
population about one-third or thirty
percent of Latin America's population is
under 15 years of age so it is a very
young population great ethnic and
demographic diversity characterizes the
region the people of Latin American
represent a mixture of various racial
groups comprised of indigenous people
white Europeans black Africans Asians
and Arabs Mexico
Central America and the Indian regions
in South America have the largest
indigenous population which makes us a
larger part of the people living in
Bolivia Ecuador Peru and Guatemala
various languages are spoken Spanish
Portuguese French English Dutch and over
30 different indigenous ones including
Quechua and I Mara Latin America has the
largest reserves of arable land in the
world it produces oil metal foodstuff it
has an impressive rich biodiversity and
astonishing natural environments the
region is home to the Amazon rainforest
the Galapagos Islands in Ecuador and the
Andean glaciers it accounts for
twenty-three percent of the world's
forests and thirty-one percent of his
freshwater resources it also houses
approximately seventy percent of the
world's species and almost twenty
percent of its ecoregions Brazil the
world's fifth largest country in area
and population has more environmental
capital and more fresh water than any
country in the world the region has a
combined gdp of six point seven trillion
u.s. dollars at purchasing power parity
three of its major economies Mexico
Brazil and Argentina are active members
of the exclusive world economic elite
g20 group according to a report and
economics and trade by the economic and
imp commission for latin america and the
caribbean o'clock better known in
Spanish as said pal in 2012 the region
is predicted to grow at three-point-one
percent this last year which is higher
than the two-point-two percent of world
economic growth more precisely the
o'clock report states that night quote
the region's economic reforms of past
decades its fiscal the macroeconomic
prudence and its sound financial
supervision together with ever closer
commercial ties with China and other
emerging economies have allowed it not
only to successfully navigate through
the worst international crisis of the
past 80 years but also to enter the new
decade with a promising outlook for
growth and advances in quality of life
and for the first time in its history
the region achieved during the past
decade a combination of high growth
macroeconomic stability poverty
reduction and improvement in income
distribution and with regard to global
economic recovery the region is today
firmly part of the solution it was that
part of the original problem and the
quote for this year 2013 growth
projection will heavily depend on the
performance of the global economy at
this moment the economic situation in
the European Union is still gloomy
recession persists in some of the larger
economies in the region and this will
surely have an impact on the South
American countries that have Europe as
his major trading partner likewise some
of the emerging economies like the
bricks which includes Brazil Russia
China India and now South Africa have
decelerated their growth and all of this
will also influence and the short term
Latin American and Caribbean economic
performance US economy regardless of
being in a better shape than the
European Union is still fragile and has
that fully recovered from the global
economic meltdown this has provoked a
decrease of us trade and investments in
the region imports have dropped from 51%
in 2002 thirty three percent in 2009 and
exports fell from sixty percent to
thirty-nine percent during the same
period in past decades President
Kennedy's Alliance for Progress
president bush seniors initiative for
the Americas and President Clinton's
call for a summit of the Americas were
all visionary and strategic proposals
designed to hands trade in cooperation
in the region none of those exist today
hence there is a growing perception that
the u.s. lacks a strategic a strategic
vision towards the region in order to
reverse that the US will need a renewed
set of policies to address the remaining
priorities of its Latin American and
Caribbean agenda
which includes issues of security crime
violence repatriation of criminals
illegal drug trafficking illegal weapons
trade human rights protection labor
rights climate change remittances and
migration yet the question does Latin
America and the Caribbean really matter
still looms out there any response we
have to say that the region is a place
of enormous contrasts it is not wealthy
enough to become a state of the art
center for international financial
transactions it is not poor enough to
provoke worldwide pity it is not
dangerous enough to generate global fear
so what is the importance of Latin
America and where does its major
contribution live for a long time it has
been considered that it is in the realm
of culture where Latin America and the
Caribbean have made their mark and built
their brand and reputation and a global
scale it has been through literature
music dance film painting and the arts
in general where Latin American soul has
been discovered who has not been touched
by gabriel garcia marquez cien anos de
soledad 100 years of solitude mario
vargas Joss's la fiesta del chivo about
the Dominican Republic's dictatorship
through here the feast of the goat or
the pawns by the Chilean Nobel Prize
winner Pablo Neruda bain't a poem as a
more eunuch and shown desesperada what
about admiring the widely recognized
artistic movements like mural ism Moodle
is mo which began in Mexico represented
by such outstanding figures as Diego
Rivera david alfaro siqueiros yoshi
clemente orozco for the paintings of
Frida Kahlo one of the most
distinguished Latin American artists of
all times who had a style that combined
realism symbolism and surrealism who has
not jumped from his or her seat at the
sound of merengue salsa bachata
vallenato or reggaeton who has not left
over the years with Cantinflas movies or
sends the emotions of Colombian soap
operas like betty la fea
Ugly Betty in addition to this notorious
cultural presence in the world for the
last three decades given the enormous
demographic economic social and
political transformations that have been
taking place in the region latin america
and the caribbean has emerged as a key
player in global affairs one that needs
to be watched closely due to the
implementation of sound social policies
life expectancy has increased from 71
years of age in 2002 seventy-four years
of age now in 2012 child mortality has
decreased significantly in the last 10
years unemployment has wrapped from nine
percent in two thousand five to six
point four percent in 2012 poverty and
extreme poverty have fallen as well from
forty eight percent in 1992 twenty eight
point eight percent in 2012 all this has
resulted in an increase of the Human
Development Index and expansion of a new
more sophisticated global oriented
middle class in the different countries
in the region through great efforts and
innovative programs illiteracy has been
seriously addressed for the first time
in the region's history access to
education has broadened making it
available to almost everyone regardless
of distance and social conditions
teacher training programs and salary
increases have been materialized new
technologies have been introduced at all
academic levels rising the efficiency
content and quality of education even
though there is still much to be done in
that field in terms of infrastructure
development the changes in nearly every
country in Latin America and the
Caribbean have been astounding and
breathtaking the skylines in major
cities have been replaced with new
buildings constructed with steel and
glass those resembling the modern view
of developed countries that can be fully
appreciated in cities like são Paulo
Mexico City Panama City Bogota Santiago
de Chile buenos aires and of course
santo domingo major improvements have
been achieved in paving roads providing
fresh water building homes for the poor
and middle-class erecting schools and
hospitals constructing subway systems
and promoting access to new information
and communications technologies Internet
in Latin America and the Caribbean is in
continuous growth at this moment there
are more than 255 million users which is
nearly half the region's population as
the World Bank established in a recent
report the region also leads in global
mobile growth with almost 660 million
mobile telephones in use that represents
a density of 107 cellular devices for
every 100 residents that means you're
more phones than people in Latin America
today nowadays Latin America and the
Caribbean nations have become urban
modern societies more than eighty-one
percent of the population lives in
cities which was exactly the opposite 50
years ago and many economic activities
have also shifted into a more service
oriented economy so there is an
undeniable sense of progress social
change and modernization taking place
around the region and the only question
or sense of uncertainty relating to its
future is about its long-term
sustainability it in order to become
sustainable and competitive in the 21st
century the Latin American and Caribbean
nations must be able to move forward
with an agenda to improve the quality of
education promote science and technology
and hence innovation diversify their
economies increase productivity and
integrate within the global chain of
production moving now towards a more
sensitive area if I may I know that due
to President Obama's recent passing an
upcoming presidential election scheduled
for next Sunday in Venezuela there is
some concern especially here in the US
about the strength and viability of
democracy in the
and about the political meaning enroll
of what has been identified as the new
American as the new Latin American left
one must remember that from some 200
years ago since achieving their
independence the Latin American and
Caribbean nations always aspired to
install democracy within their
respective societies but for different
historical reasons with only very few
exceptions these aspirations were not
fulfilled during the 19th or the first
half of the 20th century and it was only
after the end of the second world war
that a swing of the pendulum in favor of
democracy began to take place in
countries like Guatemala and Venezuela
however soon this swing began to reverse
in Guatemala have Bobo Arbenz
nationalized United Fruit Company an
American corporation and soon after the
US government intervened toppling árbenz
and the grounds of being pro communist
the Paul ward influence in blurring the
differences among US government
officials between nationalistic policies
and communism the Truman Doctrine or
policy of containment clouded the vision
of various us administrations in dealing
with the issue of nationalism and not
making the mistake of confusing it with
communism even Fidel Castro in 1952 was
running to become a member of the
Chamber of Deputies representing the
province of a Bannon when Phil Henshaw
Batista led the coop that derailed Cuba
from its democratic path during its
first stage after 1959 the Cuban
Revolution was not a socialist
revolution by a nationalist one it
appeals not to Karl Marx or to vladimir
Ilyich Lenin but more to Jose Marti
Antonio Michelle and Maximo Gomez but
castro has nationalized as arbenz did
before him American corporate interests
and as a reaction to that the invasion
of pics which was Orion
that towards overthrowing his regime
failed it was only after that episode in
1915 1961 that the Cuban Revolution
align itself with the Soviet Union thus
becoming a major player in the cold war
drama my own country the Dominican
Republic is a clear historical example
of confusion created among us
policymakers between nationalism and
communism when President Johnson ordered
a military occupation of the small
island nation to prevent that from
becoming a second Cuba what really was
at stake in the Dominican Republic in
1965 had nothing to do with a country
becoming a second Cuba it was about the
return to democracy and constitutional
order and the reposition of horn Bosh to
the presidency who had been overthrown
by a military coup d'etat in 1963 after
winning in a in a landslide the first
democratic elections that took place in
the country after the fall of the
trujillo dictatorship but exactly the
opposite occurred in neighboring haiti
were President Clinton authorized by un
council resolution ordered the
deployment of US troops to remove the
military regime installed in 1991 by a
coup de tat and restored the elected
president jean-bertrand Aristide back
into office to end his turn what made
the difference in terms of decision
making in these similar cases between
the dominican republic in haiti was one
main and single factor the cold war
which divided the world into different
lines of thought and political behavior
with the end of that historical period
the Red Scare disappeared and with it
the fear that a communist takeover might
deviate any democratic political process
it has been only during the last three
decades that democracy has been fully
established in Latin America and the
Caribbean according to recent polls
taken by highly recognized firm Latino
Varo metro at this moment there is a
high appreciation in the region of what
democracy has brought two different
nations in terms of respect for human
rights free and fair elections
freedom of the press independence of the
judiciary the respect for the rule of
law and government accountability with
the flourishing of democracy in the
region organizations that were
originally involved in armed
revolutionary struggle have put down
their arms and integrated themselves
within the democratic process to
participate through the electoral system
as a way of having access to power this
is the case just to mention three
examples of the frente faragonda marti
de liberación nacional en el salvador
frente sandanista de liberación nacional
in nicaragua frente amplio in wood why
all of which after many years of
political arms confrontation have won
national elections in a fairly manner
and now rule their countries through
democratic means during the Cold War the
left wing movement in Latin America or
any other part of the world was engaged
in a process of bringing down capitalism
as a system this is not the case in
Latin America today no elected
government in the region is evenly
remotely considering overturning the
capitalist system nowadays left-wing
politics in Latin America is more
concerned with challenging what is
called the Orthodox free market
philosophy identified as the Washington
Consensus and the floors and disparities
emerging from globalization the
Washington Consensus was essentially a
response to the micro economic crisis
that affect the Latin America and the
Caribbean in the 80s it focused mainly
on market stabilization trade in
privatization and ignore the social
issues of poverty unemployment and
social inequality this lack of human or
social element labeled as a market
center neoliberal approach generated the
conditions for its rejection in
different parts of the region trading
the breeding ground for the return of
state centric policies in Latin America
with different characteristics national
conditions international styles and
personal leadership styles it is this
view of economic and social development
centered on the state instead of the
market which has been can
as a swing to the left in thatin america
and the caribbean other elements that
have also contributed to these images of
latin america leaning towards the left
have been the fact that some elected
heads of state come from the indigenous
movement the labor unions the
progressive military or feminist groups
such as evo morales luiz inacio da silva
lula Dilma Rousseff and Latina Fernandez
de Kirchner therefore at this pivotal
moment more than the left as a dominant
force it is fair to indicate that two
opposing economic political and social
views pervade Latin America and the
Caribbean neoliberalism and Neil
populism the future of democracy in the
region will depend upon our ability to
overcome these two distinct and
contrasting paradigms instead of being
too much focused on the left or the
right what the region needs is a new set
of policies that can balance the role of
state without of the market what is also
needed at this moment in Latin America
and the Caribbean is the capacity to
integrate market forces with social
policies upheld by a culture of
solidarity corporation and partnership
for development at the beginning of this
second decade of the 21st century what
Latin America needs is more and better
democracy more sustainable economic
growth preservation of the environment
and natural resources more jobs better
quality education and health care and
widespread prosperity and opportunity
for all if you allow me I would like to
conclude by briefly referring to the
Latino community in the US and as
indicated by the Census Bureau as of
2012 there are 52 million Latinos living
in this great nation making it the
largest ethnic or race minority at this
moment they constitute 16 16 point seven
percent of the u.s. total population and
the projections are that by
t-50 will account for a hundred thirty
two million inhabitants representing
thirty percent of us total population
Latinos will continue entering the
workforce in growing numbers in 2011 it
reached fifteen percent of the total US
labor force and by 2050 it is expected
to be at the level of twenty four
percent in the last fifteen years there
has been a fifty three percent increase
of the total number of Latinos serving
in elected office which demonstrate
their growing political influence at the
government level many Latinos have
distinguished themselves in the arts
academia business politics and diverse
professional activities name suggests
Jennifer Lopez better known as JLo Marc
Anthony Carlos Santana Gloria Stefan
Salma Hayek soy Saldana a rod his real
name is Alex Rodriguez but he changed it
for a rod and Junot Diaz just to name a
few are very familiar and quite popular
around the nation which makes us us
makes us all Latin Americans very proud
of them the Latino community represents
a great force in the US as can be proven
with the fact that they have a
purchasing power of 1.5 trillion dollars
a year within the US market but also
through the results of the last
presidential elections in which it
became decisive in the outcome Latinos
made their mark an election day as they
voted for president Park barack obama's
reelection over republican candidate
mitt romney 71 percent to twenty-seven
percent and they were instrumental in
helping president obama when in two of
the key battleground states Nevada 72
twenty-five percent in Colorados 75 to
twenty-three percent in Spanish we say
Obama lady una pela
taking into account the electoral
results Republican strategy and CNN
contributor Anna Navarro who has the
National Latino co-chair of McCain's
presidential campaign stated quote if we
don't do better with Hispanics will be
out of the White House forever noting
the importance of Latinos President
Obama said quote our country was built
on and continues to thrive on its
diversity and there is no doubt that the
future of the United States is
inextricably linked to the future of the
Hispanic community beyond question Latin
America's influence has expanded at such
length around the globe that it has
recently reached the unreachable dream a
Latin American Pope el papa francisco
sitting on the chair of st. Peter in the
heart of the Vatican thank you very much
if you die like to ask question that
we've got some students with microphones
just raise your hand the president call
on you and wait for a microphone to get
to you usually shy either everybody was
convinced where I bought everybody here
right mr. president I have a question
that is related to last night's talk
which was aimed at more of the
undergraduate students in Timothy Dwight
you talked about your college experience
in Dominican Republic and it was more or
less based on a political affiliation
can you elaborate on how that plays out
for an 18 or 20 year old you know versus
the way the average yalie you know the
average American goes to college it I I
was here in the 70s and it was more like
that then here but now it you know it
doesn't seem to be particularly tied to
your political beliefs your your road
through college it's not that big a deal
but obviously it is in it was in your
day in the Dominican Republic well there
is a conventional wisdom that you tend
to learn only through academic
institutions and even though you get an
opportunity to really grow
intellectually and professionally
through academic institutions there are
other ways of learning to beyond
academic institutions and it was the
case in the Dominican Republic when I
returned at the end of the 60s beginning
the 70s and it had to do with national
conditions and what was taking place
around the world the people of my
generation became very interested for
example and what was going on in Vietnam
am a US policy towards Latin America and
the Caribbean the consequences of the US
military occupation in the Dominican
Republic in 65 so there was a generation
that was intellectually curious and that
needed to participate actively in
politics in order to contribute to a
social change in our country so that
created an intellectual environment even
at the neighborhood level were college
students were self-taught they were
reading things that were not a sign in
schools but it's just because they were
they were interested and they thought
this will be intellectual tools for
opening up their minds in understanding
what was going on in the world and so I
when I returned to the Dominican
Republic I was caught up with in that a
political and environment situation and
I think it somehow influenced me know in
in my world outlook now of course
there's another factor a and one Bosch a
former president and the most prolific
and prestigious Dominican intellectual
of all times he returned from exile at
the beginning of 1970 and began having a
daily lectures by radio a little bit
like FDR here during the Great
Depression but he was a great lecture a
great thinker and was also very
influential in shaping my generation so
in him we found a mentor first very
remote I mean he was already a
well-known Latin American intellectual
so it was very difficult to have access
to him but later on we did and we
established a personal relationship with
him and we learned reading his books and
we learned we listening to his lectures
and and through his leadership style so
there was also a mentoring from a great
figure that gave us a sense of
orientation because we're reading many
things but they didn't have like a goal
or an objective now when one bush came
and he made us become aware of the
wealth of our national culture our
national history and the need to move
forward and stabbings democracy well
then that gave us a sense of orientation
a sense of direction and that's how I
really
get involved participating through
politics and learning through politics
different ideas and different things
because perhaps the the idea that one
has is being involved in politics it's
only a struggle for power it is not true
through politics you develop many skills
that otherwise you wouldn't have it
public speaking skills organizational
skills influencing people mobilizing
people you only learn that because you
participate in through participation
there's a learning curve that will
transform you as an individual to become
really influential within your society
within your neighborhood within your
peers and I think this is the experience
that I had in the Dominican Republic
another thing one learns is everybody
has a mentor at some point in life and
later on you become a mentor to someone
else so there's like a chain of events
there like exercise chairs privilege to
ask one question yes which is presented
a compelling I thought array of factors
on which region has made consistent and
considerable progress over the past two
decades democratization yes economic
growth even relative to other parts of
the world reduction of poverty
diversification of economies even the
growth of the Latino population of the
United States and the implications that
that has or perhaps a greater region
here what's your center of anxiety what
do you what do you see is perhaps the
single greatest challenge or the thing
that you would worry about most that
could
stop or reverse some of that progress
this is interesting because we have been
celebrating since 2008 in Latin America
and the Caribbean the 200th anniversary
of Independence and as I said right from
its beginnings there was an aspiration
in in the region to install democracy
and promote economic growth and create
opportunities it never really happened
with the exceptions of few a few
countries so what really has taken place
in the last 30 plus years to generate
this political economic and social
transformation in Latin America you'll
be a mistake to look at it only from a
Latin American perspective I think it
has to do with everything that has been
taking place in the world the
democratization process did even begin
in Latin America it began in southern
Europe at the end of the 70s it came
with the collapse of the Salazar regime
in Portugal with the end of francisco
franco's regime in spain or the other
military in greece many Latin American
politicians and intellectuals were
living in Europe at that time there were
influenced by these events and so when
they came back to their respective
countries they changed their political
strategy which at that time was
confronting dictatorship with socialism
and then they figured out that it was
more difficult to confront alpharetta
regimes presenting an alternative to the
system and instead they said instead of
of dictatorship versus socialism or as
they framed it at the time fascism
versus socialism it was more
dictatorship versus democracy so there
was a there was a change in the mindset
in Latin American intellectuals and
politicians for the first time accepting
democracy in modern times because
democracy was disdained at some point
because every time there was there was
an attempt to install the marker see
there will be a military coup de tat and
perhaps US government officials aligned
themselves with the nude
there was a lot of frustration with
democracy in Latin America and some
would say bourgeois democracy or you
know lament a la representative ah that
mentioned representative system but
after that after what happened in
southern Europe there was a new mindset
with that I think there are two other
factors that play an important influence
in this transformation from dictatorship
to democracy there's a man that I think
has not been given enough credit for
everything he did in allowing this
transition to democracy in Latin America
and that is President Jimmy Carter with
this human rights policy and pressing
for free and fair elections at the end
of the 70s Jimmy Carter really made an
important contribution to political
change in Latin America the other have
to do with social democracy in Europe
they have an organization called
socialist international which is not
Marxist is more democratic oriented and
they had an opening for Latin America
and then traditional populist Latin
American parties begin part became part
of this organization and so coming from
Europe and coming from the US there was
a lot of pressure to organize democratic
elections free and fair elections and
beginning in the Dominican Republic in
1978 there has been a third wave of
democratization after the Second World
War and for the first time there has
been no reverse in this situation so in
Latin America we all think that
democracy has come to stay and that we
are more now consolidating democracy
consolidating democracy and working how
government can be more efficient how can
it be more transparent how can it be
more accountable how can it deliver what
the people is expecting from a
government than ever before this never
took place before so having resolved the
political question of stability of how
do you have access to power you can even
consider what i said in my previous
remarks organizations like a friend s
and anita liberación nacional which came
to power in 1979 through an armed
struggle lost elections 10 years later
and came back to power again through
electro means so everybody has accepted
the rules of the game that it is through
free and fair elections that you have
access to power now for the population
that is a great achievement but not
enough because at the end of the game e
at the end of what you are making as a
proposal what is the economic and social
evolution of society and there have been
many reforms the Washington Consensus I
think has a merit and that it correct
that some of the problems of the
previous economic model which has more
King even in the term in the sense that
it it emphasized macroeconomic stability
it emphasized fiscal deficits correction
combating hyperinflation so all these
things were good but still not enough
because they didn't have an impact in
the well-being of the population so what
has been questioned on the Washington
Consensus it is that is too technocratic
and it forgot what policy making is all
about is having people as as the
targeted element to which you have to
influence so going beyond the Washington
Consensus the new government in Latin
America have installed social policies
the whole idea that if the economy grows
it will trickle down and have an impact
is being rejected in Latin America and
you have to combine solid macroeconomic
policies economic growth with active
social policies aimed at improving the
quality of people this combination has
made the difference in Latin America
with economic growth governments now
have had resources to invest in
infrastructure development which means
better schools better hospitals better
roads this transformation has been
because of that now looking forward once
again the region is not isolated it is
part of what is taking place on a global
scale much of the success in the last
decade has been that southern countries
Brazil Chile Peru Argentina have had
closed trade links with China China has
made an inroad with
america and the caribbean and i will say
South America at this moment is more
connected with China in Asia than ever
before now Mexico Central America and
the Caribbean are more more integrated
with the US economy the Dominican
Republic is more integrated with the US
and of course it has to do with
geography is the geographical proximity
that we have with the u.s. it also has
to do with the presence of a population
here Central America the Caribbean
islands have a Latino a Latino Diaspora
that connects with the US and their
respective countries is less South
America which always had more close
relationship with the European countries
that with the u.s. so if there is a
deceleration of economic growth in China
for example or in Asia these countries
will be hurt because their exports have
been going to China if China demands
less copper and less and less zinc and
less food stuff so their economies will
drop and we already can see that China
was growing twelve percent a year this
past year decelerated to seven percent
and now the Brazilian economy is only
growing 1.5% in 2012 so we depend on
that the future of Latin America then
first of all will depend and how the
global economy performs if the US
economy picks up again and you can have
2.5 three percent growth that will have
a tremendous impact in that America
especially in Mexico if the US economy
starts booming up again it will pick up
on Mexico that is is poised to be also a
country with a great potential for
economic growth and sustainability in
the years to come if Europe can get out
of its current recession it will also
have an impact in that American the
Caribbean now on the domestic side we
have had a decade of great success but
also we have some challenges the
question of sustainability what is the
question of sustainability for Latin
American and Caribbean economy has to do
with the fact that we have been
exporting raw materials we have been
exporting natural resources with no
productive transformation so the real
thing now is how can we add value to our
products and services how can we be part
a global chain of production and that
can only be done through knowledge so
the quality of education is key
improving our universities we're very
preoccupied with with a standard of our
universities in Latin America and the
Caribbean when you see University
Rankings World University Rankings the
first one that appears in the ranking
from Latin America and the Caribbean is
la universidad nacional autónoma de
mexico unum and it figures out number
two hundred number two hundred and then
after that sao paulo is there a
university that fidelity valeriana
janeiro but all after the two hundred so
we're not competing internationally in
terms of producing knowledge and
generating new patents to be registered
now intellectual property rights we're
lagging there so that America needs a
policy for science technology and
innovation we need to protect our
indigenous knowledge with new
intellectual property rights this is the
way to move forward and wait for that we
need public-private partnerships in
order to invest in an innovation and
technology and science we need to create
a culture of Science in Latin America
over the years we have been promoting
soft science everybody studies law or
studies marketing or studies management
soft science now we need engineers we
need scientists that can pull all their
knowledge in place and and and really
make this transformative production of
our raw materials into new goods and
services if we're able to improve the
quality of education to innovate to
integrate within the global economy that
I think Latin America will become a
major key player in global affairs
you're ending your speech speaking about
Latinos in America which is a growing
population huge and we taught you talk a
little bit about the 16 point seven
percent of the population is Latino here
fortune 500 company CEOs is only one
point seven percent have six CEOs for
the fortune 500 what steps outside of
education and mentorship because there's
very few mentors because not a lot of
people that are in that position but
what other steps can we can we take to
bridge that gap of that you know I think
that is the main road ahead is education
it has to do with with innovation with
vision forward and and creating some
sort of Latino organizations that
already exist and supporting each other
and coming out with new ventures coming
out with new fresh ideas that will have
an impact in the US so but the key to
everything has to do with education and
perhaps we're not there as CEOs and
those fortune 500 companies because
there is still not some gap in terms of
knowledge between the Latino community
and other communities here in the US I
will always emphasize the role of
Education to move up the ladder you can
see that for example you have Sonia
Sotomayor coming out graduate from from
Yale but coming from Yale she makes it
to the Supreme Court you say so it's
education at the end the bottom of
everything is education mr. president
grass no mr. president talking about the
future or Latin America how do you
foresee the strengthening of regional
groups to participate as a block in the
global economy the GDP of El Salvador is
not the same as an Argentina or the GDP
of Jamaica is not the same as as Brazil
and those our economies are growing
because of the demand of resources from
China the resources that we held in our
lands arable land portable water
precious
not precious metals are going to be
demand that in the future from Europe
from the United States and other parts
of the world so wouldn't the Latin
America benefit from a cohesive union a
group so just gonna sue but at much
larger scale don't you see the new force
see the regional group group in Latin
American countries will benefit the
region as a whole thank you yeah I
totally agree there is an integration
process taking place in an America at
different levels it has always existed
at sub regional levels the Caribbean
countries for example are within CARICOM
if you add Dominican Republic Haiti and
Cuba it's called caddy forum and the
user has a platform to negotiate with
the European Union then you have in
Central America seeker sistema de
integration Center America is also
integration if you had Mexico to Central
America it's called Mesoamerica and they
also negotiate and in South America you
have the Andean packed well packed on
Dino and then you have met Koecher in
the south and now they have created una
sure the problem is that we have too
many organizations that are overlapping
each one with the other politically we
have created something new that I hope
it can work it's called selac ammonia
italo's américa latina el caribe and
select is supposed to be one voice
representing politically political
dialogue Latin America with the rest of
the world what's lacking is that is not
a formalized institution it is the chair
changes every year from one country to
the other so i think the perhaps we have
to work more on that to have a one voice
representative of latin america i give
you an example we have three countries
as i mentioned before brazil mexico and
argentina that are members of the g20
group how proud are we as Latin
Americans to have three countries that
are in that elite club nevertheless when
they go to those meetings they go with
their own agenda they don't represent an
American the Caribbean we hope that
within selac we can get together and
design a policy that will work
in the interest of all that America that
doesn't exist until now so there is ICB
the idea of integrating the idea of
cooperation south-south cooperation
creating new institutions for example
financial institutions that will finance
projects in latin america with i would
say conditions that are not within the
commercial banks these kinds of things
are interesting also in the energy
sector for example you can have it in
educational exchange within Latin
American countries so these are all new
initiatives that we did not have before
the idea of cooperation the idea of
solidarity the idea of coming together
is something also new in the region that
is enhancing our possibilities of
increasing our economic growth and
social well-being Senor Presidente it is
a real honor to have you here at Yale so
thank you for being here and thanks for
all the Dominicans who are here visiting
as well I would like to invite you to
discuss a little bit more the conflict
you noted between neoliberalism and neo
populism I'm particularly interested in
how you view this translating into
global trade dynamics and what types of
trade agreements Latin American and
Caribbean countries and specifically
Dominican Republic if you wish to
comment on that would view as
advantageous for example one might
associate neoliberalism with the
incredible rise in bilateral investment
treaties that that we saw in the 90s and
early 2000s right agreements such as dr
CAFTA and NAFTA and now in more recent
years with one might say the neo
populism rise in Latin America we see at
least two if not three Latin American
countries rejecting and challenging eXID
the World Bank dispute resolution
framework for for investment state
treaty disputes and we see South Africa
which obviously not part of the region
but a notable actor who
as I understand it has called for an end
to entering into bilateral investment
treaties so how does this all translate
into what types of agreements are Latin
American countries and Caribbean
countries in particular rethinking as
advantageous to its own interests and
how do you equate that with this neo
populism neoliberalism divide that
you've noted okay I think there's a
combination of different elements here
no it has to do with political ideology
it has to do with economic interests and
also with a particular moment in history
not in current and contemporary history
for example looking from the trade side
we had in Latin America and the
Caribbean more specifically what was
called the Caribbean Basin initiatives
okay or CBI with CBI all the Caribbean
countries were allowed to export their
goods and services into the US market
and a duty free basis unilaterally with
the exception of Nicaragua and Cuba
excluded for ideological political
reasons at the time but the thing is
that there was a an incentive to export
within the largest market in the world
which is the US market unilaterally this
was done to help the Caribbean countries
overcome their internal problems and
somehow to stop massive illegal
migration coming from the Caribbean into
the US this was the logic of all this
now after the end of the Cold War a
unilateral free trade access into the US
market coming from the Caribbean becomes
a reciprocal free trade treaty between
the Caribbean and the United States and
this creates a problem in the sense that
we're dealing with a an economy of scale
which would be the US economy with very
small poverty written economies in the
Caribbean in this sense of a symmetry or
disparity how can it be tackled and of
course there is no answer to that and
I'll just give you a
an example I think I talked to with the
students yesterday about Haiti for you
to understand Haitian workers produce
rice in the Dominican Republic but they
don't do it in Haiti why not because
Haiti imports all its rice from Arkansas
which has which is subsidized by the
local government the production and the
export so it's cheaper for Haiti to
import rice subsidized rice from
Arkansas than to produce the themselves
so in that case it is very difficult to
have reload real free trade where there
is a disparity or a symmetry between two
different scale of economies this is a
problem for the future because even
though it has been considered gradually
that's that the economy will open
gradually to the import of us goods and
services also Europe because we have
signed free trade agreements with Europe
you will take 20 25 years they say to
have fully open the market to the
imports of goods and services but even
then in 25 years from now many of our
productive sectors will be will be
harmed by the opening up of this market
so this is something that's still
pending that we have to work on and see
exactly how we can benefit our our
population back in the Caribbean finally
a neoliberalism and your populism I
think at the center stage of political
philosophical debate worldwide is the
relationship between state and market it
is a relationship between a conservative
movement which things that market should
buy themselves determine the outcome and
performance of societies in every aspect
that markets are self regulating even
though what happens with the reason
global financial crisis proves that
markets are not self regulating and
those that have gone to the other
extreme to think that the state should
play the pivotal role in any
decision-making that is required by the
economy economic sector by society we
call those that have made the the faith
in the market as the only solution to
every problem
the neoliberal proposal and the other
which has a state centric solution to
everything is a Neil populists the idea
is that both are needed you need a
market to operate but you also need a
strong government to intervene on
occasional on specific occasions in
order to guarantee some sort of
equilibrium social equilibrium within
society that you do through your tax
system so the combination of state and
market will give us a new paradigm going
beyond neoliberalism a neo populism
there are positive things in both I mean
you cannot condemn and reject everything
that comes from a liberal viewer
conservative view Clinton here in the US
took some ideas from the Riggin movement
Tony Blair in the UK took some ideas
from Marco Thatcher he came into the
center if you are able to balance the
relationship between state and market
you might become more effective it
really satisfying people's needs in
terms of opportunities and growth and
etc so this is what I think is not only
Latin America is worldwide this this
debate about the role of the state in
the market I think there's a question
over here right all right I'll respond
the last one which is easier of course I
do bachata and the first one I think is
one of the most challenging problems
were having a Latin America and the
Caribbean right now the drug trafficking
issue and and violence related to drug
trafficking and the only way I think
this can be addressed is through a
partnership between the u.s. in our
countries back home there has been at
some points a marked interest in
building up in this partnership but
nevertheless
I think much more can be done over more
than 20 years of addressing this issue
with a certain perspective it has not
worked out I think a new set of fresh
ideas must be put in place there is a
need to enhance the dialogue between
Latin America and the US and how to
tackle this problem now yesterday in the
press I read something that really
concerned me that is taking place here
in the US because from Latin America we
have the supply side in the u.s. you
have to demand side of this market
yesterday in u.s. USA Today I read that
a group of young businessman were
creating a corporation equity investment
to buy off some companies and from their
purchase marijuana and the US which will
be legalized in many states so when you
think that there is a group already of
people thinking here and doing business
and making profit out of selling
marijuana it might indicate that there
is a trend to the legalization of drugs
for business / for business business
purposes and profit making which I think
would be a wrong thing to do I think
drugs is that alcohol we all know that
drugs has an impact in people's brains
in people's behavior it also has a
health issue health care issues not only
the business side or you know the
criminal side of it has to do with
people's behavior people's attitudes
people's way of relating to each other
in society so it's still a problem has
not been addressed effectively when you
look at the way the tourist issue is
being dealt with and you look at the way
the drug lords are being treated there
is a difference I think we have to look
at the drug lords and the tourists the
same way because they represent both a
threat to the well-being and stability
of our societies and I don't think that
they are looking at the problem with the
same way okay um so mr. president um so
a lot of your focus is on educate
and relating to a question that was
asked earlier on about like a fortune
500 in the representation of Latinos
Latinos aren't represented a majority of
the high-profile positions and as you
said this relates to education Latinos
here in the United States have the
highest dropout rate of any any ethnic
or racial group and so a lot of that
there are many factors going into that
economics for class but part of it does
have to do with the discrepancy between
education here in the United States and
in the home countries so since the US
population of Latinos is going to
increase so much in the future this is
obviously of importance to both the US
and to Latin America so in what ways do
you think Latin America can improve on
its education what you see now in
Latinos within the US making progress in
some sense no even though still when you
look at the statistics there below some
other some other groups it has to do
with the way now a wave of migration
came into this country the the group
that has traditionally migrated are
those that are under class in Latin
America and the Caribbean those are the
poor who have migrated into into the US
so it has taken them a while to get
integrated within a modern society as
the as the u.s. Society you have to
learn a new language you have to learn a
new culture you have to be part of the
system in order to really participate so
it has taken i would say 30-40 years for
our people to be part of the american
dream to be part of the American system
now a second a third generation has born
in the US I think it's your case and
look what is happening now we have
Dominicans at Yale University it is you
would have never thought about having
Latinos or Dominicans at Yale University
20 25 years ago it was impossible now
you're here
and master benzyl and if the US in the
years to come these dominicans most
likely will be Dean's and masters here
in at Yale University because of your I
would say your innovative spirit know
and your capacity to to work so looking
into the future will have a new
generation of American born Latinos
which will have a great command of the
English language will be by cultural
from the beginning it will have more
opportunities in access in this society
to move up the ladder so the future of
Latinos in the u.s. is much brighter
than what has been up until now because
new opportunities will come to them it
is already happening I mean just think
of the idea that we have a Latino
justice at the Supreme Court just think
of the idea that when President Obama
addressed the state of the union address
who responded him a Latino from the
Republican Party Marco Rubio the senator
from Florida and now the Republicans are
thinking to put a Latino and the
electoral ticket in 2016 to compete with
the Democratic Party so the Latinos are
really moving up there they're being
considered an important sector in in US
but I insist in order to really make a
mark in really and really to move on as
a community as families as individuals
as communities the key to success is
education back in our countries also the
main target the main objective is how
can we improve education because we as I
said in my remarks we have nowadays
improved access to education in the
Dominican Republic there is ninety
ninety nine percent access to education
the problem is that access anymore the
problem is the quality of education then
it has to do with teacher training
programs the use of new technologies the
idea of learning a new language of
becoming digital literate of having a
global outlook because nowadays you have
to be you need to
a global outlook is not only your
country because you will be interacting
with different parts of the world doing
it with limited resources as we have had
in that America makes it more difficult
but if we have a Latino diaspora that it
is interacting with their respective
countries that makes it easier I come to
Yale I talk to a group of students here
and everybody is excited and the
possibility of connecting with students
from the Dominican Republic in different
exchange programs now if can you imagine
a student from universidad autónoma de
Santo Domingo coming for a seminar or
workshop at Yale University this is a
major revolution for him he will connect
with professors new reading lists
students that will open up their minds
with new ways of thinking so when they
go back they go back with new tools new
new ways of thinking new ways of doing
that will revolutionize things this is
why I think the best way to really make
an impact in terms of economic
development is through exchange exchange
of ideas you never know exactly how you
touch a person how you change a person's
lives just by the sole fact of
exchanging ideas and opinions so I
believe in that and by having you here
the Dominican students association in
the Latinos Association there is a great
wealth of opportunities for exchange and
really continuing this path of social
transformation in our countries in Latin
America and the Latino community here in
the US right
thank you for coming today I think maybe
the president will be able to to shake a
few hands here for a few minutes but
then we have to get him to another place
so good evening good luck enjoy the warm
weather he brought it in from Santo
Domingo